I can tell you personally seeing a lot
of vaccine injuries that that's very
real data that's been published it seems
to suggest the more vaccines people get
the more susceptible they are actually
to co so I think the great experiment of
saying we're give people vaccinate all
these people and then we're going to
lead to a decrease in coid didn't play
out to be true and as a result more
people are getting coid but they're also
suffering from lots of side effects of
something that was untested why is it
affecting the heart so much so it may be
that there's some underlying issue with
their heart the immune system again is
is not handling the overwhelming immune
response that the vaccine is triggering
but I've seen things with the heart
people have had Strokes a lot of
autoimmune stuff and then we're also
seeing a lot of what they're calling
turbo cancer where people are getting
very aggressive cancers